Jagdish Bhagwati the university
professor of economics and law at
Columbia University i was born in bombay
now known as mumbai in 1934 and i was
deeply influenced by the fact that the
good people from the state of gujarat
because the whole state bifurcated into
gujarat and maharashtra once you know we
got independence and people states of
reorganize along linguistic lines it
used to be a common which is known as a
bombay presidency and was split into two
and i was part of the Gujarat faction
and Gujaratis actually are traditionally
very much oriented to its business the
they're the ones who went all over into
Africa and all over the world that the
biggest community of Indians abroad one
thing in which the gujaratis have on top
of that is a very powerful traditional
social work and gandhi the great gandhi
was at himself a Gujarati and he built
on that tradition he didn't invent it so
he what he did was to essentially
harness this for social good in a very
big way so every family were actually
he's involved in I came from legal
family but my father you know fought for
independence and my eldest brother
became the chief justice of india and
set up the entire legal assistance legal
aid program and also public interest
litigation so the big bridges built
after you know on for him villages named
after him because he was a great radical
force for the this ran in the family the
reason why i got interested in economics
was because when i started studying
economics i realize it was a unlike law
which my parents wanted me to get into
that time law was not seen the way it is
today's as
is something where you can do public
interest litigation you can do pro bono
work it was just supposed to be you know
X versus Y and Regina versus Bryan and
use case law and nothing really
interesting but I could see my teachers
and Cambridge England were the ones
where i first started doing economic
seriously at the age of 19 that is where
they were all oriented to his social
work so like one could see economics not
just as a bunch of chess problems or
mathematical problems but sometimes some
people do but it's simply an instrument
for bringing about an uplift people and
coming from India and with this
background I was just a patsy for it he
became my vocation well I think this one
comes read as it gives the diversity
which is simply that my fault father
came from very poor family his own
father was a primary school teacher so
my father was went through on charity
and disclosures entirely all the ways it
was high degree of social mobility but
they were all within that generation my
you know my pipe 73 now almost and I'm
talking about something like 110 years
ago in in here and they were all very
puritanical they I mean the kind of
upbringing my have which was too you
know for all the seven sons that my
father had plus three cousins who wasn't
growing up with that he was bringing up
ten children in the family and there was
no luxury no comfort nothing we think
any money there was no quivery earning
money in those days like American kids
do so the only money that you got was
from your parents and we didn't get any
you know we weren't allowed to go to
restaurants Midway meaning there was no
money for restaurants money before about
two movies a year and we
had we were I didn't wear a long pant it
was over short pants and until I live
for Cambridge England at the age of 19
we always used the buses no taxes no
cars and so on but at the local
bookstore there was an open account and
I you know each of us with scallions of
books and education was number one
priority and that really whenever I get
an Andhra degree you you know I always
tell the kids you've got to thank your
parents because without that you
wouldn't be here now because they gave
you the values and in many cases they
also gave you the money to be able to do
your education so that that really cut
across so so one rather big can the
Chief Justice of India another you know
the president of the International
pediatric neurological society my
younger brother became president of the
world foundry Association because he's a
PhD in metallurgy and so and I've I'm no
slouch in economics that's four out of
seven and that's a pretty high ratio but
it was entirely due to this values which
we had and I think it's also students
all in good stead because we were like
my neurosurgeon brother was really one
of india's leading neurosurgeons he
could have settled on in Chicago where
he did his basic work when he went home
and today he does neurosurgery on people
you know poor people no cost no charge
and he charges of course it he the rich
people but that is that's sort of built
into our system so even when I do
something like free trade and people say
oh gosh you've got to be a devil with
horns if you believe in free trade is it
look just hold back because I like free
tray not because I'm like I'm into
corporate interests at soccer corporate
corporate interests are in to what I
believe it
era I want to do it because i think it's
going to lead to a growing prosperity
and it's going to draw people into and
two more prosperity but and but it's not
to said it's the only way to do i
frequently will have to supplement it
with other policies so but it is a
principal instrument for at least
development